[Musique]
Michel Denisot a affirmé sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il était en possession de la
fameuse liste des 26 l'huile c'est
peut-être c'est un coup de bluff et vous
est-ce que vous avez des infos je crois
que Karim Benzema sera en équipe de
France
attaquant oui Sam ben yeder Karim
Benzema Kingsley coman
Ousmane Dembélé Olivier Giroud
Antoine Griezmann Kylian Mbappe Marcus
sur Anne merci Jésus pour le retour de
Benzema dans l'équipe de France voilà
les Didier Deschamps il faut qu'il
pardonnent on est d'accord Benzema il a
eu des choses mais le gars il joue quand
même il m'a quoi il a reçu des trophées
il passe encore il est tout il est tout
barré
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
spectaculaire aussi cette course de
cartes ça se passe en Belgique à Genk 15
pilotes au total regardez bien vont
rater ce virage on sait pas pourquoi un
bon la 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 le page précise
question pourquoi ils ont raté ce virage
ils n'ont pas vu peut-être qu'il y avait
la buvette qui a été ouverte peut-être
qu'ils étaient déjà des confinés en
Belgique en tout cas on sait pas vous
avez une covid oui bon et alors vous
avez dit que vous avez été soigné par
Didier Raoult avec de l'hydroxy
chloroquine mais du pastis vous êtes
sérieux oui
d'abord vous êtes allés à Marseille où
vous avez échangé avec lui au téléphone
et il vous a dit de prendre du pastis
est-ce que ça j'ai jamais entendu ça on
voit les ravages de cette génération de
médecins dans son gâtés qui ont oublié
quand ils ont commencé leurs études de
médecine de faire un peu de philosophie
de réfléchir ça donne en fait ce que
j'appelle moi des Boves de la médecine
ce sont des gens
de réagir c'est la deuxième fois que je
insulté par ce mec ça suffit
ça fait deux fois que vous insultez la
première fois
de la médecine et ça va bien vous le
diluez dans l'eau j'étais un cobaye et
il m'a dit vous inquiétez pas vous allez
survivre et vous le diluez dans l'eau le
pastis ou vous le prenez comme ça dans
l'eau non je le prends normalement comme
on le prend à Marseille pour moi mon
pote je suis mal tricoté P2 alors bof de
la médecine et cetera je veux dire c'est
vrai que j'ai pas eu le temps de faire
des philosophie je touche la retraite
des ouvriers des problèmes donc alors
c'est bon le problème ça va bien et et
j'ai connu et j'ai connu la période
heureusement en fait de médecine euh
faire médecine en étant littéraire donc
c'est bon qu'il arrête de nous insulter
ce type il faut au moins de doses pour
mais comme le vaccin astre alors c'est
comme le ricard c'est deux doses
le premier soir euh j'ai pris un verre
ballon le deuxième soir un verre à
Ricard à Bastille et là ça allait
beaucoup mieux au bout de trois jours
j'étais guéri
je claque la porte un nom sans être
monté sur scène hein
j'aime pas trop cette plainte tout le
temps on n'a pas pu monter sur scène on
a manqué au public le public nous a
manqué
c'était mondiale donc là vous avez fait
la voix
mon métier
c'est d'être moi
j'adore faire des conneries et faire
rire les gens et aujourd'hui je suis
payé pour c'est pas magnifique
Ilan est l'un des candidats
emblématiques de la télé-réalité
d'aujourd'hui j'ai tout
pour
ces 99 % de ouais je sais
je pourrais pas être une star avec le
autochtone
[Musique]
attention je suis enchantée
pour une story Instagram on est sur 2000
euros
pour une snapchat on est sur 2200 euros
ça c'est ce que vous facturez quand vous
faites une story pour une marque quelque
soit le produit ouais
également des trous sur les côtés non il
n'y en a pas donc c'est par sa bouche
le parfum s'évacue
après pour un poste sur le fil
d'Instagram on a 4500 euros
d'accord donc quand vous mettez une
photo qui va rester sur Instagram c'est
4500 euros le tarif un mois
certains candidats font jusqu'à 10
placements par jour Luis est un
internaute lambda un habitant du Nevada
avec 4000 abonnés au compteur mais
surprise sa dernière vidéo de 3 secondes
comptabilise plus d'un million et demi
de vues la raison des internautes
français le comparent masse à l'ancien
Premier ministre Edouard Philippe pour
sa barbe partiellement blanche seulement
voilà Luis n'a aucune idée de qui est ce
fichu Édouard Philippe quand on regarde
vos stories il y a de tout ça peut être
des produits alimentaires des bougies de
la nourriture pour chien vous vendez un
peu tout et n'importe quoi bah c'est pas
tout n'importe quoi si tu as un chien
moi je suis une boutique en ligne entre
guillemets il y a une boutique vous
allez au magasin en bas acheter des
croquettes vous allez aussi trouver
plein d'autres choses et ben moi c'est
pareil quel est ce terme formé à partir
du grec zoone
signifiant être vivant qui désigne la
branche de la biologie ayant pour objet
l'étude des animaux oui
[Rires]
je me suis même fait tatouer son visage
[Musique]
ah ouais
Gaëlle littéralement étymologiquement
c'est l'amour des animaux c'est l'amour
qui aime les animaux donc
le monde d'après réel n'a rien à voir
avec les fantasmes sur le monde d'après
de nos bassesses à nos bons sentiments
nous sommes exactement les mêmes il y a
rien de nouveau sous le soleil que vide
ou pas donc en somme le monde d'après et
bien c'est le monde d'avant empire voilà